foreign
[Music]
CBS deals and this morning we have three
products that may give you a reason to
stay in bed and pamper yourself
especially on these kind of cold nights
it's all they are all at exclusive low
prices so to start shopping now scan the
QR code on your screen or visit
cbsdeals.com
lifestyle expert Ashley Bellman joins us
more and we are going to be warm I am so
happy that we have this product this is
the calming heat sauna wrap I'm just
going to get right in it if you don't
mind because it's very cold here today
this is just like a sleeping bag you
jump in it put it on your bed any flat
heat resistant service oh thank you yeah
get in with me it's so warm
[Music]
it's really warm it's warm it vibrates
you can control it with the remote
179.99 today at cbsdeals.com 40 off my
mom I told her I was get I was doing
this today she couldn't believe it she's
been looking for something like this
because she has problem sweating she's
like you know how important sweating is
to detox the body burns calories and I
don't know about you but I enjoy burning
calories laying down very nice it's 40
off this is something that is going to
warm you up it's the infrared heat it's
the vibrations it's just all around good
and it feels nice to be warm and it will
shut off after 30 minutes if you oh
that's that's key yes you have something
else for the bed something else in the
bed okay this is called better better so
I always sleep better I'll get this you
go down oh thank you I always sleep
better in hotels and I think it's
because it's the perfectly made bed all
the sheets are tucked in so nicely so
this is a headband it goes around the
back said king or queen starting at
23.99 you tuck the fitted or the flat
sheet into it and it's going to give you
that perfectly made bed always and then
at night when you're sleeping is going
to stay nice and tucked also I love that
I can put on the side my Kindle which
always gets lost in the bed I'm always
yelling at my husband accusing him of
stealing it when he did nothing the
remote it's the remote the glasses the
perfect Hospital Corner what more can
you have exactly no right then and 40
off again king or queen size this is
something no excuse for not being able
to make the bed anymore well what do we
have here okay so from blast Beauty we
have the Smart Eye massager the eye mask
that's only 9.99 55 is the savings today
you put that on to protect your eye
makeup and then put the eye massager
over there's different settings it's
going to oscillate it's going warm it's
going to de-puff de-stress get you ready
for bed get you early in the morning or
for the morning and if maybe you look at
a screen all day this is the perfect
solution right it's good good and then
you also have the blast Beauty balm
which is vegan cruelty free this really
great formula 19.99 for the balm it's a
stick you can use it to even out your
uneven skin tones this is like the go-to
anything you need bomb does it hydrate
hydrates all the good stuff and I love
that it's so easy it's so compact take
it with you anywhere use it all in
combination so put it on put on the mask
and then put on the massager or use them
one by one but 19.99 the mass 9.99 this
is 76 55 off cbsdeals.com like those
percentages off Ashley as always thank
you of course of course we partner with
all of these companies to get these
deals so to buy anything you saw today
just scan that QR code on your screen or
head on over to cbsdeals.com